merci d'être avec nous Céline vous
voulez espéronier nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure et du
de Paris à parenté au groupe les
républicains on va évidemment parler de
votre proposition de loi sur l'uniforme
à l'école dans quelques instants mais
d'abord la réforme des retraites puisque
c'est le jour Jerry XII qui a l'air par
temps pour voter ce texte question de
cohérence et de responsabilité pour la
droite dit-il vous êtes d'accord avec ça
bien entendu à horizon 2027 notre
système sera difficile de 42 milliards
d'euros c'est ce que disait François
Lenglet sur une chaîne concurrente hier
soir
on a 13 millions de Français qui ont
plus de 65 ans aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
une personne sur 5 et à horizon 2070 ça
sera une personne sur quatre
d'autre part il y a bien évidemment trop
peu d'actifs par rapport au nombre de
retraités et ce sont les actifs qui
financent les retraites dans les années
70 on était à quatre actifs pour un
retraité aujourd'hui on est à 1,7 actifs
pour un retraité donc les chiffres sont
là à partir de là on a trois solutions
où on augmente les cotisations
et dans un contexte où pouvoir d'achat
est totalement en berne c'est bien
évidemment hors de question où on baisse
le montant des retraites même chose que
pour le point numéro 1 ce n'est pas
possible donc seule solution augmenter
le nombre de cotisants donc augmenter
l'âge de départ j'allais dire c'est
presque tout simple quoi c'est une
réforme que votre aide d'autant que le
gouvernement c'est un lignée sur ce que
votre Sénat depuis des années difficiles
pour vous de vous y opposer bien
évidemment on est cohérent il y a aussi
une question de moments de calendrier on
sait que les Français vivent une période
difficile notamment avec les hausses des
prix les questions de pouvoir d'achat
est-ce que c'était le bon moment de
faire cette réforme alors là vous posez
une question qui est cruciale comme très
souvent malheureusement le timing n'est
pas optimum on a l'impression quand même
d'une sorte de précipitation et d'un
manque de pédagogie or on a vu pour les
différents projets qui avaient été
proposés par le gouvernement ces
dernières années il y a souvent eu la
précipitation à manque de pédagogie avec
les résultats qu'on a connu
rappelez-vous ce fameux système par
point qui devait être mis en place du
temps de Monsieur Delevoy et qui a
avorté complètement donc j'allais dire
le gouvernement ne peut plus rater le
problème qu'on a avec cette réforme
c'est qu'elle n'a pas d'assis populaire
on voit bien que il va y avoir des
contestations sociales
il y a une assise intellectuelle bien
entendu mais qui n'est pas toujours
compris par nos concitoyens donc ça va
tanguer j'ai envie de dire de manière
triviale cela dit il va falloir tenir
bon parce qu'il faut sauver ce système
par répartition et vous avez le
gouvernement à tenir bien possible et on
gouvernement va aider le gouvernement à
te dire bon maintenant la méthode ça
n'est pas nous on déplore cette méthode
et on a quand même assoupli en demandant
de 65 à 64 ans on a travaillé aussi sur
sur le nombre d'années de cotisations ça
devrait pouvoir bien la méthode parce
que beaucoup de comptes de concertation
le l'annonce de la réforme à me mettait
reportée pour laisser encore plus de
temps voilà concertation il y a une
covid il y a des Français qui sont en
proie beaucoup de difficultés de
questionnement de doute cette réforme
des retraites elle pose la question
qu'on a dans le rapport au travail
de la durée de vie de allongement de la
vie
quel sens elle travaille aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on a envie télétravailler
est-ce qu'on a envie de travailler plus
longuement est-ce que est-ce que est-ce
qu'on a des est-ce que les gens sont
toujours
convaincus par le travail qu'ils font
tout ça ça aurait dû être questionner
bien en amont je trouve et je trouve
qu'il y a quand même un peu de
précipitation en tout cas si la réforme
est présentée de manière trop compliquée
on a le gouvernement aura du mal à le
faire passer mais pour autant il faudra
quand même vous parler de la scie
circulaire il y a aussi une opposition
unanime de tous les syndicats mais
jamais vu depuis 12 ans est-ce que ça
c'est un problème est-ce qu'on peut
passer une telle réforme sans la vague
d'aucun syndicat c'est un problème mais
j'allais dire il y a des syndicats qui
sont dans leur rôle ce qui est plus
peut-être un problème par rapport à
Emmanuel Macron c'est les relations
qu'il a eu assez conflictuelles avec
Laurent Berger la CFDT là on voit qu'il
a peiné à le convaincre alors que de
mémoire la CFDT a toujours accompagné
les projets de loi alors le report de
l'âge a toujours été un point de
désaccord très très fort avec la CFDT
mais
de manière générale a toujours
accompagnée là visiblement ils seront
dans la rue et les positions sont durcis
donc ça va être compliqué mais il faut
créer de la richesse vous savez moi je
reviens aux années Mitterrand un
Mitterrand a été passé de la genre très
de 65 à 60 ans après les socialistes
dans un milieu 35 heures et aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas s'en sortir en France si
on ne crée pas de richesse de richesse
donc cette réforme elle est bien
évidemment nécessaire s'il y a pas de
richesse il y a moins de services
publics les hôpitaux les écoles etc
enfin vous connaissez tout ça par coeur
donc de toute façon il faudra tenir mais
la méthode s'épanoue nous on votera en
responsabilité maintenant si la méthode
est mauvaise on ne peut présager de rien
ne pas voter comment non non normalement
on vote ce qui a été décidé puisque
quand même un certain nombre de choses a
été pris en compte c'est l'une des
inquiétudes de Laurent Berger c'est que
certains Français qui ont fait leur 43
unités ne soient pas en mesure de partir
à la retraite parce qu'il n'aurait pas
64 ans parce qu'a priori c'est l'âge qui
sa retenue est-ce que vous comprenez ça
est-ce qu'il faut donner la primeur aux
annuités sur le l'âge légal moi je
trouve que les annuités de 43 ans c'est
plutôt une mesure qui est relativement
une mesure pédagogique et d'équilibre et
de et d'égalité après on verra comment
sera débattultes et ce qui va en
ressortir mais je pense que compte tenu
de la pyramide des âges contenu de
l'allongement de l'âge en France
aujourd'hui il est difficile de ne pas
parler de report de l'âge bien
évidemment il y a un autre point sur
lequel
Erik sotti demande au gouvernement
d'infléchir c'est la question du minimum
retraite 2200 euros qui doit s'appliquer
selon les LR à tous les retraités c'est
à dire aux retraités actuel également et
non plus seulement au futur retraités
comme le souhaite le gouvernement est-ce
que Gabriel Attal a raison d'alerter sur
le coût de cette mesure pour les
finances publiques bien évidemment
puisque le Sénat en premier aussi alerte
sur la fuite en avant de la dépense
publique si vous prenez uniquement les
retraités entrants et que vous les
mettez à 1200 euros c'est un coût
globalement de 50 millions érosion 2027
si vous prenez les retraités qui sont
déjà à la retraite en plus c'est à dire
de manière rétroactive c'est un coup
peut-être de 30 milliards d'euros donc
ça fait un delta qui est évidemment très
important on doit le noter maintenant on
ne peut pas dire que les retraités
aujourd'hui soit des personnes qui
soient Nantes donc c'est une maison
c'est aussi pour vous parce que c'est
une ligne rouge pour se tire est-ce que
c'est aussi une ligne rouge pour vous
que ça pique à tous les retraités de
toute façon il faut que le gouvernement
qui est dans une logique visiblement
puisque comme vous le savez il est dans
une majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale le gouvernement qui est dans
une logique de vouloir notre aide pour
voter ce texte doit prendre en compte ce
que lui demande le parti les
républicains moi j'attire l'attention
sur le fait que ce sera une mesure qui
sera beaucoup plus coûteuse donc j'ai
entendu des commentaires disant que
avant de rapporter de l'argent c'est
vrai que cette réforme risque d'en
coûter un petit peu B les retraités ont
besoin de mesures en faveur de leur
pouvoir d'achat ce ne sont pas des
nantiges je le rappelle donc c'est
plutôt une bonne mesure on va continuer
sur l'actualité parlementaire on va
parler de votre texte c'est que vous
présenter avec d'autres de votre
collègue de vos collègues à l'air un
texte pour imposer le port de l'uniforme
à l'école dans les collèges et dans les
lycées on va ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex où ça
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour Céline boulet et
Alex que prévoit donc précisément la
proposition de votre Céline voulait
faire ce texte propose de rendre
obligatoire une tenue vestimentaire
uniforme dans les écoles primaires les
collèges et les lycées laissant aux
établissements la liberté de définir les
caractéristiques de chaque uniforme elle
la proposition de loi prévoit également
le versement par l'état d'une allocation
pour les familles modestes pour qu'elles
puissent acquérir cette tenue alors
actuellement si l'uniforme n'est pas
obligatoire à l'école et bien un
établissement scolaire a parfaitement le
droit de l'imposer en modifiant le
règlement intérieur pour les sénateurs
les républicains
uniforme à l'école et bien ça
permettrait de renforcer le sentiment
d'appartenance à l'établissement
scolaire de minimiser le risque de
raquette de et bien mettre un petit peu
plus de discipline et puis surtout de
régler la question du port de vêtements
religieux à l'école avec les polémiques
récentes dont on parle sur le port de
Rob islamique qui laisse les professeurs
un petit peu des trop savoir s'ils
doivent ou non exclure les élèves qui en
portent notez qu'une autre proposition
de loi du rassemblement national à
l'assemblée a été déposée elle va être
discutée ce jeudi au Palais Bourbon et
même si et bien au sein de la majorité
présidentielle il y a des députés qui
sont favorables à l'uniforme obligatoire
à l'école et bien le ministre de
l'Éducation lui et totalement opposé on
va l'écouter je ne veux pas ouvrir ce
débat en tout cas à l'échelle nationale
je ne veux pas de loi sur ce sujet
imposer le port de l'uniforme à tous les
élèves c'est non en revanche
les établissements en toute liberté par
une modification de règlement intérieur
pour imposer s'il le souhaite une tenue
scolaire mais je mets en garde contre
celles et ceux qui pensent que le port
de l'uniforme réglerait magiquement les
problèmes
qu'est-ce que vous répondez au ministre
qui estime que le retour de l'uniforme à
l'école ça va pas vraiment résoudre les
problèmes dans l'encein scolaire alors
c'est un débat et un sujet qui n'est pas
nouveau donc à tout le mois il
mériterait d'être discuté le ministre
non seulement dit qu'il trouve que ça
n'est pas une bonne idée mais refuse
même d'en discuter il ferme la porte
tout court dans une situation qui est
quand même relativement complexe pour
l'école qui est en proie de nombreux
doutes et de nombreuses difficultés
première chose deuxième chose il
justifie sa fin de nos retours par le
fait que ce n'est pas la solution
magique mais qui a prétendu que le port
d'une tenue d'établissement scolaire
imposée serait la solution magique
personne donc ces arguments sont
parfaitement de mauvaise foi et je
dirais même que ils sont presque
coupables de ne pas prendre le sujet à
bras le corps donc pour compenser
j'allais dire comme je vous le disais
c'est un sujet qui n'est pas nouveau qui
est un sujet de conviction pour nous et
pour moi en particulier mais aujourd'hui
même pour compenser le laxisme du
ministre les parlementaires que nous
sommes vont prendre leur responsabilité
en ayant déposé ce texte et en le
discutant au Sénat je l'espère au
printemps parce alors le retour de
l'uniforme à l'école vous le dites c'est
pas une recette magique mais qu'est-ce
que ça va apporter selon vous l'avez
parfaitement des crises que ça va
apporter à mon avis il n'y a que du bon
dans cette proposition de loi vous avez
décrit un certain nombre de choses c'est
une loi qui est sécuritaire c'est-à-dire
anti raquette c'est une loi qui favorise
le fait de pouvoir travailler ensemble
qui favorise un projet d'établissement
une unité au sein de l'école comme dans
une équipe sportive où on porte le
maillot parce qu'on appartient à une
institution à l'école je vous rappelle
qu'en 2015 il y a un excellent rapport
qui a été fait par Jacques gros Perrin
qui mon collègue sénateur qui est
d'ailleurs cosignataire de cette
proposition de loi qui s'appelait faire
revenir la République à l'école et ce
rapport conclué au fait que il y avait
un délitement qui était jugé inquiétant
du sentiment d'appartenance à la nation
donc il faut recréer ce sentiment
d'appartenance et puis même si c'est pas
menacé universelle c'est une bonne
première mesure dans une école qui en
proie de nombreux problèmes manquent
criant de professeurs
inattractivité du du
pour le métier d'enseignant
de savoir fondamentaux qui s'écroule des
des bâtiments qui tombent en ruines
enfin il y a beaucoup de problèmes qui
touchent l'école et voilà que on n'a
jamais autant parlé du vêtement qui est
au centre de l'école alors que je
souhaiterais moi que les enseignants que
la communauté pédagogique que les chefs
d'établissement soit délesté de ce
problème dont on te parle que trop donc
évidemment que ce n'est pas la solution
magique mais en tout cas ça
simplifierait un certain nombre de
choses pour la communauté pédagogique et
moi c'est ce qui m'intéresse ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a une trop
grosse responsabilité sur les chefs
d'établissement puisque aujourd'hui
c'est à leur discrétion mais bien
évidemment et puis en plus on voit
toutes ces atteintes à la laïcité alors
vous disiez je suis pas totalement
d'accord que c'était la mesure
principale de cette proposition de loi
vous avez remarqué que dans l'exposé les
motifs on n'a pas commencé par ça parce
que c'est d'abord une mesure qui est
importante pour les enfants eux-mêmes
avant même le collectif sachant que
l'indépend de l'autre et après bien
entendu dans la dans l'actualité on a vu
qu'il y avait eu des attentes à la
laïcité le ministre a sorti une
circulaire le 9 novembre 2022 qui n'est
pas satisfaisant et qui ne donne pas un
cadre précis aux enseignants et en plus
il dit je vais pas moi-même vérifier si
les abayas sont des vêtements etc donc
il y aura plus de problèmes si on met en
place le l'uniforme c'est une mesure qui
est très égalitaire socialement
d'ailleurs quand on interroge les jeunes
ils sont plutôt pour ils sont plutôt
favorables parce qu'ils aiment ces
notions de solidarité et d'égalité et
donc je n'y vois que des aspects qui
sont clairement ça vise les tenues
islamistes ce texte est certainement pas
ça vise d'être dans l'esprit de la loi
de 2004 et c'est une mesure de
neutralité l'uniforme à l'école pour
l'appeler comme ça mais vous avez vu
qu'on l'a pas appelé comme ça mais
l'uniforme à l'école c'est une mesure de
neutralité qui rejoint l'esprit de
neutralité de la loi de 2004 donc il n'y
a pas de il faut dessaler
2004 qui interdisait le port de signe
religieux à l'école pour vous ce texte
est plus suffisant au vu de l'actualité
pas forcément suffisant je vous dis la
circulaire du 9 novembre n'y a rien
changé et d'ailleurs on le voit
puisqu'il y a des attentats la laïcité
qui ont tendance à augmenter mais
surtout ce qui est beaucoup plus
inquiétant c'est que très souvent les
chefs d'établissement ne signalent pas
les attaques à laïcité qui ont été
faites parce que ils n'ont pas de cadre
précis et par conséquent le port du
vêtement est soumisa interprétation
qu'il aimait eux-mêmes dans une
difficulté voir dans un danger donc
cette loi qui est une loi de
responsabilité propose de mettre un
cadre clair et de dire tout le monde est
sur un pied d'égalité et je vous dis
c'est une mesure qui est très favorable
pour les enfants parce que ça crée un
sentiment d'émulation une appartenance à
une équipe voilà toutes sortes de choses
qu'on n'a pas forcément le temps de
développer ici encore une fois on en
discutera au sein dans l'hémicycle au
printemps mais on est prêt vraiment
aller jusqu'au bout c'est le moment
peut-être un mot sur la liberté scolaire
on entend souvent les défendre la
liberté des établissements scolaires en
l'occurrence chaque école peut imposer
ou non l'uniforme pourquoi ne pas garder
cette liberté
il faut une orientation nationale si je
vous disais je vous prends l'exemple de
Provins où il y a eu une expérimentation
qui a été faite il y a quelques années
dans 8 écoles de la ville l'initiative
du maire et bien comme ça n'a pas été
rendu obligatoire pourtant les écoles
avaient travaillé avec les parents avec
les enfants et tout comme ça n'est pas
étendu obligatoire l'uniforme n'a
quasiment pas été porté donc il faut une
impulsion nationale mais pour compenser
ce côté impulsion national par la loi on
a décidé parce qu'on est quand même en
2023 donc il faut de la modernité de
décliner la loi au niveau local en
demandant en laissant l'autonomie à
chaque établissement de décider de sa
tenue scolaire pour deux raisons d'abord
vous n'aviez pas un enfant de la même
manière qu'il soit en Haute-Savoie ou
dans le nord de la France ou qui soit à
Nice ou à Marseille donc il y a cette
souplesse là qu'il fallait avoir et puis
deuxièmement il y a aussi un enjeu
financier donc ce sera chaque
établissement qui décidera de sa tenue
en concertation avec les enfants avec
les familles il prendra le temps qu'il
faut et je pense que ça assouplit le
côté direction nationale mais il faut
cette pour l'imposer et donner une
direction que ne donne pas le ministre
aujourd'hui avec tout de suite une
obligation sur tout le territoire ou
est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir des
obligations expérimentales dans certains
territoires avant le généraliser on en
parle depuis très longtemps je vous dis
à des expérimentations qui ont été
faites et qui ont donné de bons
résultats mais à mon avis pas suffisant
donc maintenant on donne une direction
légiférant là-dessus et on verra les
aménagements qui peuvent être faits au
texte au printemps Alex le rappelait il
y a un texte similaire qui va être
discuté à l'Assemblée nationale dans la
niche du rassemblement national ce sera
jeudi est-ce que pour vous les députés
les républicains doivent voter ce texte
du rassemblement national alors comme je
vous le disais notre texte est beaucoup
plus abouti on a pris le temps d'y
travailler il y a des exposés des motifs
qui ont été développés il y a une mesure
financière dans ce texte ce qui n'est
pas le cas je crois dans le texte du
Front national d'ailleurs le Front
national bénéficie d'une niche le 12
janvier dans lequel seront débattus
plusieurs textes ça va aller très très
vite peut-être qu'ils n'auront même pas
le temps de débattre ce texte qui a été
rejeté en commission parce que comme je
vous le disais l'exposé des motifs
n'était pas assez about il y avait pas
de mesure financières
donc je pense que donc vous dire ne
votez pas celui-là attendez que le nôtre
arrive à l'attente moi je le pense alors
je comprends la tentation des députés LR
qui sont de dire il faut quand même
avancer sur ce texte dans nos
circonscriptions on comprendrait pas on
en parle depuis des années mais le texte
a été un sujet donc avec ce type parle
depuis longtemps mais le texte il a été
rejeté en commission parce qu'il a pas
été assez travaillé on voit la tentation
de l'affichage du Front national qui
vient d'arriver qui se dit vite vite
faut avancer sur ce sujet alors que je
vous dis nous on y réfléchit depuis très
longtemps merci Alex à tout à l'heure on
parlera réforme de retraite
et on va parler d'un autre sujet du
présenter hier par le gouvernement c'est
son plan pour sécuriser la pratique de
la chasse c'est la ministre la
secrétaire d'État à l'écologie la
présentée hier dans le Loiret justement
on va aller dans ce département à
Orléans on retrouve Éric Richard bonjour
Eric merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à La Nouvelle République et
Éric après des mois de débat Bérengère
Couillard la secrétaire d'État donc
présenté son plancha depuis le Loiret
vous avez assisté à cette présentation
qu'est-ce que vous retenez de ces
annonces
d'abord disons une sorte de mise en
scène annoncée dès la fin de la semaine
dernière à la presse une annonce donc
faite vous l'avez dit à DRI instinct
village du Loiret alors pourquoi DRI
bien parce que ce village abrite le
Centre national de formation des
fonctionnaires de la police de
l'environnement qui se veut une vitrine
également des bonnes pratiques en
matière de biodiversité Bérengère
Couillard la secrétaire d'État à
l'écologie bien c'est voulu rassurant
disons en prenant je cite le retour
d'une situation apaisée pour le partage
de l'espace rural pour ombre avec toute
polémique elle dit également se placer
je cite encore loin aussi bien des
incantations de certains radicaux
anti-chasse que de l'immobilisme prenait
par certains chasseurs bon c'est clair
ça le mérite d'arrondir les angles
disons avec tout le monde et pourtant
hier matin Adrien il manquait des
interlocuteurs essentiels il y avait
bien
les associations
lié à l'espace forestier il y avait bien
l'office français bien sûr de la
biodiversité mais pas de représentants
des chasseurs qui n'avaient pas répondu
à l'invitation pourtant lancer en bonnet
du forme les limites peut-être de cette
écologie apaisée voulue par le
gouvernement pas vraiment punitive pas
vraiment écologique aussi diront
certains qui veut tenir compte de chacun
mais pas toujours aussi rassembleuse
qu'elle le prétend en cela et bien les
annonces gouvernementales ont été hier
une illustration de ceux qui ne parvient
pas tout à fait à être un consensus
eric a eu notamment des néanmoins des
annonces concrètes à annonce concrète
fait en faveur d'une sécurité accrue de
cette pratique de la chasse
ouais alors d'abord il y a ce point vous
savez central sur lequel le gouvernement
bien ne cède pas on le sait c'est le
fameux jour de nonchas le dimanche ou un
autre jour pour la mini c'est une fausse
bonne idée qui avait d'ailleurs été
initié il y a une vingtaine d'années
sans grand succès une fausse bonne idée
en ce qu'elle ne résout pas les
questions de sécurité sur les 6 autres
jours de la semaine là évidemment c'est
pas contestable sur le formulaire tout
de même des avancées concrètes d'abord
sur une formation renforcée des
chasseurs avec la formation initiale
bien sûr mais également ce qu'on appelle
la formation des Sénats une remise à
niveau donc d'un niveau qui sera accru
mais aussi les chasseurs également les
organisateurs de battus c'est très
important ça représente au total selon
la ministre environ 200 000 personnes
qui seront formées d'ici à 2025 qui
recevront en tous les cas une action de
formation ensuite il y a dans ces
annonces une meilleure information des
Prom est plus largement des usagers de
l'espace rural une information affichée
en mairie sur les temps de nonchas mais
aussi une application dont on attend un
petit peu la praticité en quelque sorte
une application mobile donc pour une
information précise et en temps réel des
usagers de l'espace rural sur les zones
chassés ou non et puis surtout il y a
cette réponse à cette aberration il faut
bien le dire le contrôle de l'alcoolémie
et de la consommation de stupéfiances
songez que jusqu'à lors il n'est pas
répréhensible de tenir un fusil chargé
en main de s'en servir et d'être en état
débriété ce sera donc désormais une
contravention dans un premier temps
ensuite et la sénatrice connaît bien ce
cheminement on attendra bien sûr une loi
qui sera semble-t-il calquée sur le code
de la route et qui fera donc pour la
consommation d'alcool ou de stupéfiants
qui fera donc un délit et ça évidemment
en matière de sécurité c'est tout de
même une avancée
Eric vous avez une question pensez-lui
une boule d'expérience
bien tout simplement et même si ces
questions qu'on vient d'aborder ne sont
pas au cœur des préoccupations
quotidiennes des habitants de la
capitale néanmoins l'espace rural est
évidemment l'affaire de tous quel regard
tout simplement
portez-vous bien sûr ces annonces
concernant la chasse
alors je me félicite du fait que le
gouvernement soit parti d'un rapport
sénatorial de mon collègue Patrick chese
qui a dégagé plusieurs pistes puisque
la chasse
la question de la cohabitation avec les
promeneurs notamment posent la question
du partage de l'espace naturel vous
l'avez dit dans un contexte de mentalité
quand évolué et c'est souvent un débat
qui est explosif si vous me permettez
cette expression
un sondage de l'Ifop qui date de
décembre je crois dit bien que 78% des
Français réclament dimanche en chasse
dimanche qui a été instauré dans de
nombreux pays européens je comprends que
ça ne puisse pas être le cas en France
bien que j'aurais aimé quand même que et
puis et puis être envisagé une
demi-journée pour contenter tout le
monde pourquoi ça peut pas être le cas
en France pourquoi
il faudrait poser la question au
gouvernement de toute façon à partir de
là il y aura une loi aussi dont on
débattra et qu'on pourra amender dans
quelques mois au Parlement le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité aller dans
ce sens il a trouvé deux choses le
contrôle de l'alcoolémie et de
l'alcoolémie pour moi c'est bien la
moindre des choses si vous êtes un
cycliste et vous faites arrêter avec un
gramme dans le sang vous êtes sanctionné
donc quand on porte un fusil j'allais
dire c'est pas une annonce
révolutionnaire c'est moi la monnaie ça
aurait dû être mis en place à mon avis
bien avant quant à la mise en place
d'une d'une application oui ça me pose
quelques questions parce que ça veut
dire que effectivement on considère que
si la multiplication était mise en place
alors elle peut être mise avant parce
qu'il y avait des dangers sur certaines
zones de chasse au moment où il y avait
des promeneurs et puis qu'est-ce qui se
passe si un accident c'est de la faute
de l'usager qui n'a pas été sur
l'application parce qu'elle peut être
compliquée pour des personnes un peu
plus âgées et tout bon cela étant dit
vous connaissez un peu ma position sur
le sujet
c'est pas les chats traditionnels qui me
posent le plus de difficultés moi j'ai
un tropisme pour la condition animale
vous le savez mais je pense qu'il y a
des sujets qui sont prioritaires
j'aurais aimé qu'on parle un peu plus de
la chasse à courre on en parlera
peut-être dans le texte des choses
traditionnels et puis l'élevage
industriel les abandons tout ça sont des
sujets qui sont prioritaires par rapport
à l'achat à la chasse traditionnelle bon
donc j'espère que ces avances suffira
mais encore une fois on en débarras dans
quelques semaines merci Eric Richard
merci d'avoir été avec nous et
évidemment on regarde la haine de la
Nouvelle République plancha et sécurité
des réactions contrastées c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci Eric Richard ah
non puisque je sais Céline vous laisse
pour unique vous suivez attentivement
l'actualité outremanche notamment
l'actualité de la monarchie britannique
et c'est donc aujourd'hui que sortent
les mémoires du prince Harry qui font
trembler du côté de Winter il n'est pas
tendre avec la famille royale
particulièrement avec son frère William
est-ce que pour vous ce livre est les
interviews qui donnent peuvent mettre en
danger la monarchie britannique
alors oui et non on est habitué un peu
aux frasques de la famille monarchique
j'ai presque envie d'avoir une pensée
globale pour mes amis anglais que j'aime
beaucoup le l'Angleterre est une pays de
tradition un pays tradition auquel je
suis particulièrement attachée et qui
traverse une période extrêmement
difficile à une inflation qui explose à
10 ou 12% des grèves dans tous les sens
des Britanniques qui n'arrivent plus à
se nourrir et ce n'est pas être
caricatural que de le dire donc c'est
vrai que par rapport à ça les phrases
que de la famille et les mémoires du
prince Harry peuvent sembler
anecdotiques cela dit je pense que ce
prince vraiment en souffrance je pense
que le peuple britannique est attaché à
sa famille monarchique et surtout dans
un pays en proie au doute et aux
difficultés que je viens d'évoquer la la
reine mère Elizabeth II qui était un
gage de stabilité pour cette famille
vient de mourir et c'est vrai que ces
mémoires tombent plutôt mal mais je ne
pense pas qu'elle mette en danger la
famille marché qui en a vu bien d'autres
à la traversée des guerres à la
traversée des situations familiales très
difficiles c'est peut-être de nature à
renverse à la renforcer et ce sera un
excellent test pour le nouveau roi dont
on voit qu'il fait plutôt un début
rassurant pour les Britanniques qui ont
besoin de cette figure tutélaire donc
j'espère que ça se passera le mieux
possible pour nos amis anglais bref
merci beaucoup Céline d'avoir été avec
nous dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on va reparler bien sûr de
la réforme des retraites puisque c'est
le jour J elle sera présentée en fin de
journée pareil les Abed born 3 sénateurs
seront avec nous pour en parler mais
d'abord on accueille notre prochaine
invité cette année